The final structural type of UML diagram that I'd
like to mention is the Profile Diagram. But this requires taking a step back.
UML itself is a language, that has various pieces to it,
such as classes and associations and so on. Those pieces.
Essentially provide a, describe a system and
therefore you could have a UML description of UML.
That UML description or UML is called the UML meta model and
in fact you can have, a UML class model diagram of a UML meta model.
Even, more abstract is the fact that you,
as a user, a designer, can extend the UML middle model.
You can add new kinds of icons. You can give, special labels.
To particular elements in the model. You do that extension in what's called
a UML profile. And there's a UML Profile Diagram in which you can convey it